[Musique]
non
20h l'événement avec une nouvelle page
d'actualité dans cette émission
bienvenue à vous qui nous rejoignent et
sur canal + nous avons connu l'été de
tous les incendies avec des feux qui ont
ravagé la côte d'azur la californie le
canada et même le groenland la planète
brûle et nous recevons les spécialistes
jean marc jancovici et polar nous pour
commenter cette actualité dramatique
alice le feu est aux portes de los
angeles et il a déjà brûlé deux mille
hectares de forêt et il menace le
quartier où se trouvent la plupart des
studios de cinéma à burbank en
californie les images sont effrayantes
sauf que cette fois ce n'est pas un film
et le même scénario s'est déroulé cet
été un peu partout sur la planète
nicolas herbaut le gouverneur de
californie a décrété l'état d'urgence
depuis ce week end le feu est aux portes
de los angeles et il continue de
s'étendre mais celle incendie le plus
important des 50 dernières années
cet historique ses épaisses broussailles
n'ont pas brûlé depuis 45 voire 80 ans
par endroits et les entretiennent
aujourd'hui le feu
malgré les moyens engagés 2000 hectares
sont partis en fumée et 700 habitations
ont été évacuées
on ne veut pas partir on se sent même
démuni et moi j'ai envie d'être utile
peut-être que je peux encore faire
quelque chose si je pars c'est vraiment
terminé
la maison est construite en bois il
suffit d'une étincelle et je peux lui
dire adieu le feu et tout puissant et si
le vent se lève là les ennuis commencent
et le vent s'est levé
attisant ce gigantesque brasier les
températures caniculaires plus de 40°
n'arrange pas les choses
l'ouest américain l'ouest du canada
aussi connaît les pires feux de forêts
depuis 60 ans plus surprenant le
groenland s'est lui aussi enflammé cet
été cette zone située au dessus du
cercle polaire arctique a vu partir en
fumée
15 kilomètres carrés de toundra et de
tourbe
le phénomène n'est pas nouveau mais très
impressionnant il est accentué par le
réchauffement climatique et la fonte de
la glace
le ciel de la méditerranée a vu s'élever
de nombreuses colonnes de fumée en
tunisie en grèce ou dans les balkans
comme ici en croatie
des dizaines de feux de forêts ont fait
rage sur la côte adriatique tout l'été
les habitants ont lutté comme ils ont pu
contre les flammes
83 mille hectares ont brûlé une surface
deux fois plus importante qu'il ya cinq
ans même superficie calciné au portugal
durant le seul mois d'août les incendies
majoritairement volontaires attisée par
cette sécheresse extrême dans le pays
ont mobilisé entre 3 et 4000 pompiers
tous les jours des foyers de tailles
variables les plus grands sont devenus
incontrôlables
[Musique]
de l'espagne à l'italie en passant par
la france jamet depuis 15 ans cet arc
méditerranéen n'a été autant frappé par
les incendies
on sera sur un secteur du feu sur
lesquels paris les bulldozers de façon à
mon ouvrir des pistes qui vont nous
permettre d'aller très loin
la côte d'azur et la corse ont beaucoup
souffert
un été intense pour les canadairs qui
dans le sud-est du pays comptabilisent
26 mille heures de vol deux fois plus
que l'an passé
il faut savoir qu'en en europe du sud
les les surfaces susceptible de brûler
pourrait tout simplement doublé au 21ème
siècle
bonsoir jean marc jancovici soit merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous ce soir en
direct dans cette émission vous êtes
ingénieur consultant en énergie climat
fondateur de l'agencé carbone 4 votre
dernier livre dormez tranquilles
jusqu'en 2100 je reviendrai sur le titre
est publié chez odile jacob en
collection de poche on a franchement
l'impression que le poumon vert de la
terre est en train de brûler les forêts
pour qu'elle se porte bien il faut
qu'elle soit dans des conditions dans
lesquelles il pleut de temps en temps
ayez pas de stress hydrique et
thermiques qui fasse qu'à un moment tout
part en fumée
parce qu'un arbre ça mais quand même
quelques dizaines d'années a poussé est
en fête avec le réchauffement climatique
on est en train d'assister aux
déplacements vers les pôles de zones qui
sont globalement plus chaudes et
malheureusement pour nous sur le
pourtour de leur comédie dernier un plus
sèche on peut se permettre pardonnez moi
de dire ce soir très clairement à la
lumière de l'été que nous sommes en
train de vivre et on évoquait encore il
ya quelques instants
le nombre d'incendiés incroyable qui
avait en europe enfin bon on va dire
tout autour de la planète
cette fois ci c'est clair le
réchauffement climatique il joue un rôle
même si on sait très bien que certains
incendies sont volontaires oui il joue
un rôle au sens où il augmente la
température moyenne et ils augmentent
sur le pourtour méditerranéen le degré
de sécheresse et donc il rend plus
favorable les conditions du départ de
feu ou du maintien d'un départ de feu
qu'est ce qu'on fait à votre question il
ya des mesures de très court terme et
des mesures de mon chat et long terme la
très mauvaise nouvelle c'est que le
changement climatique est un processus
nous réversible c'est à dire que il faut
plusieurs milliers d'années
gym ya plusieurs milliers d'années pour
que l'excès de co2 qu on a déjà dit dans
l'air secure plusieurs milliers d'années
nous ne reviendrons jamais en arrière ni
vous ni vos enfants ni vos
petits-enfants niveau arrière petits
enfants ne reverront plus jamais le
climat de l'an 1900
j'avais fini et l'inertie du processus
fait que en fait même si on arrêtait des
maîtres demain matin ça continue enfin
les conséquences vont continuer de
s'amplifier pendant encore quelques
décennies à quelques siècles et voir
quelques milliers d'années pour
l'élévation du niveau de l'eau donc il
ya un premier sujet sur la partie
atténuation ce qu'on appelle
classiquement atténuation dans le
domaine de la lutte contre le changement
climatique qui consiste quand même à
essayer de ne pas en rajouter
parce qu'au moment où comme petit gibus
on dira si j'avais su j'aurais pas venu
il sera un peu tard pour dire finalement
on met les compteurs à zéro
après il ya sachant cela il faut que la
collectivité des hommes les pouvoirs
publics les individus etc s'organisent
pour éviter de faire le moins de bêtises
possibles dans ce genre de contrat quel
moment et à quel degré dites vous la vie
n'est quasiment plus vivable sur cette
planète
l'homme est un animal tellement
ubiquiste on s'accroche partout donc
toute la question est de savoir vous
savez à un moment la population humaine
était de 5 millions d'individus
donc si la question où la survie de la
population humaine je suis pas très
inquiète parce qu'il fait 60 degrés en
été dont des centaines deviendra
difficile 300 des pôles vous aurez
toujours des endroits où ce sera à peu
près viable donc là encore une fois la
survie de l'espèce il suffit de quelques
centaines de milliers ou quelques
millions d'individus
ça c'est pas en jeu par contre le fait
quand vous dites par des mois qu'on vous
employer l'expression en répondant à
alice la survie de l'express vous
suggérer l'idée
il peut y avoir des lits des milliards
de disparus et qu'on est pour composer
une humanité aujourd'hui on décompte de
l'image que vous nous donne alors ce que
je suis en train de vous dire c'est
qu'aujourd'hui vous n'avez pas un
scientifique sur terre qui est capable
de vous donner une borne supérieure au
nombre de gens qui verront leurs
conditions de vie soient leur vie
supprimés soit leur condition de vie
terriblement affecté par le changement
climatique
personne ne peut vous dire ses 520
millions 1,3 ça va s'arrêter là voilà
y'a pas
y a pas de raisonnement qui permet
d'argumenter en dix ans à l'as limité à
tant de personnes qu'est ce qu'on fait
quand même parce que je n'ai pas obligé
pas oublié ma question vous faut éviter
de reproduire des bêtises mais qu'est ce
qu'on peut encore faire j'ai un peu de
foot a quitté en dix minutes de temps de
parole je vais sortir quelques
généralités
c'est l'oeuvre d'une vie quelque part
c'est à dire qu'à partir de maintenant
le monde de demain sera plus jamais
comme le monde d'hier est donc il faut
insérer sa dans énormément de choses qui
régissent la vie des hommes dans les
plans d'urbanisme dans la manière
dont on s'implante ou pas dans la façon
dont on gère les forêts dans la façon
dont on punit ou pas les gens quand on
les attrape
enfin énormément plu donc de tout dire
car vous avez raison de me faire la
remarque en 10 minutes mais choisissez
un thème très précis que vous avez envie
de développer en quelques mots pour dire
voilà à quoi on sera confrontés d'une
façon non c'est un peu ses impressions
ce qui vous tient à coeur joie
c'est un peu systémique cette affaire là
un exemple parmi d'autres on peut dire
il faut plus de moyens de prévention
mais dans un pays à budget limité si
vous donnez plus pour ça vous donnera
peut-être moins aux écoles ou au moins
aux maisons de retraite
est-ce qu'on est d'accord ou est ce
qu'on n'est pas d'accord donc c'est très
difficile enfin si je disais quelque
chose il ya qu'à faut qu'on en l'espace
de dix secondes
je serai un imposteur ou un escroc c'est
plus compliqué que ça on a marqué des
points quand je vous écoute et je me dis
on a déjà gâché la planète notre planète
et le mode de vie qu'on pouvait espérer
y avoir on on est déjà au delà de l'un
d'eux lors c'est très clair c'est à dire
qu'on va déjà payé une partie de la
facture de ce qu'on a fait c'est
absolument évident on est en train de
commencer à voir
c'est très très difficile la question du
changement climatique parce que les
hommes sont ainsi faits on est des
animaux de chair et de sang concert
avoir peur un truc qu'on a déjà vu mais
avoir peur d'un truc qu'on n'a jamais vu
c'est pas habituel du tout non et c'est
peut être par exemple cette chose qu'on
n'a jamais vu le changement climatique
quand on vous a dit on risque quelques
degré d'élévation de la température en
un siècle
en fait ça fait appel à un truc qui ne
s'est jamais produit dans l'histoire des
hommes
j'ai quelques degrés de différence de la
température moyenne c'est la différence
entre une ère glaciaire est aujourd'hui
bon donc c'est un changement massif ça
roule c'est paléoclimatologue le savent
mais par contre savoir ce qui peut
arriver à quelques milliards d'hommes
sédentaires si on fait la même
expérience en un ou deux siècles on sait
pas il faudrait avoir 450 planètes dans
le système solaire on aura déjà fait
l'expérience puis là vous pourriez
prendre la longue-vue regarder mais on
n'a pas ce banc test donc on est forcé
d'avoir peur une construction
intellectuelle et déjà si vous avez des
enfants vous savez que leur faire
prendre peur d'un truc qui est déjà
arrivé à des centaines de milliers
d'enfants c'est compliqué en plus avoir
peur de quelque chose qu'on n'a jamais
vues avant c'est c'est encore plus
compliqué et c'est la raison pour
laquelle au fur et à mesure que les
conséquences du changement climatique se
manifestent certaines étant parfaitement
attendu les départs de feu encore une
fois ça fait partie des conséquences
attendues on se dit ah qu'est-ce qu'on
peut faire mais malheureusement il ya
une partie maintenant qui est dans une
mécanique engagé
donc on peut prendre des mesures
curatives et qui dans un contexte dans
lesquelles les moyens sont pas infinies
seront nécessairement au détriment
d'autres trucs qu'on aurait pu faire
ailleurs
alors la france n'a pas été épargnée par
ce phénomène seize mille hectares ont
brûlé cet été le week-end dernier encore
les pompiers ont dû lutter contre les
flammes dans le département du var
aujourd'hui une partie de la corse est
toujours en risque incendie sévère
comment vivre face aux dangers du feu
reportage à cisco dans le cap corse
d'alix vente paix et louis 6000 à
quelques pas de sa maison
cet habitant a une vue imprenable sur
les dégâts
lavallée a été ravagé par les flammes il
y a quelques semaines on a eu très très
peur
voici les stigmates de l'incendié du 11
août qui s'est arrêté aux portes des
habitations
donc c'était tout près voilà la grandeur
du camion de pompier côté flamand qu'un
simple échelle et la dimension de les
flammes
donc ça c'est le lendemain je suis monté
un peu plus aulas sur une maison en
construction dessus donc ça va donner ce
spectacle petite maison l'astre convoi
dessus avec des vents violents dans la
région le feu peut se propager
rapidement le dernier a parcouru plus de
1800 ha non peu habitué encore c'est
donc quand on sait très bien qu'un jour
ou l'autre on risque d'avoir un ancien
un incendie sur sa commune mais si on
pouvait passer l'été sans ça serait
beaucoup mieux
après chaque incendie l'esisc et doivent
se faire à ce décor un paysage lunaire
fait de braise et d'arbres calcinés
pour éviter un nouveau drame
gilbert car à cause y travaillent
bénévolement pour la mairie il passe ses
journées à traquer d'éventuels pyromanes
un peu neuneu pas démarre jamais seul
c'est tout vert encore vraiment si ça
brûle en aiguille dès que j'aperçois une
fumée suspecte ou que je regardais que
je voyais un également sur les pistes en
4 4 qui gravite un peu je surveille à la
jumelle mais guettait tous les véhicules
n'est pas toujours facile ouais la fumée
qu'on voit là la fumée c'est la
poussière sa région j'aurais dû le vent
lorsqu'il était en bas maintenant il est
au virage j'ai derrière le truc noir et
on ne le verra pas et ça c'est pas un
véhicule de service des forestiers y
sont jaunes et avait aussi des pompiers
rouge intérieurs de voitures plus bas
dans la vallée
un autre décor ici la nature a repris
ses droits après un violent incendie en
[Musique]
ce sapeurs forestiers a vu le mac qui
repoussèrent à l'identique
en fait ça vous avez un à rouges et si
vous revenez l'année prochaine par
exemple au printemps vous allez avoir de
suite les premières pousses vertes qui
vont partir du pied on va pas rembourser
sur une estrade comme ça donc ça repart
au sein des initiales avec l'herbe le
pied d'arbousiers qui repousse et le
prix de pied de brière et ses terrasses
apprendre ça monte ensuite une fois
arrivée une certaine hauteur vous avez
le chêne qui commencent à émerger un
circuit la faune devra elle aussi se
réadapter au nouvel environnement
le temps du renouveau c'est aussi celui
du sursis avant un nouvel incendie les
pompiers et la mairie de cisco donne des
conseils à adopter devant les flammes en
cas de feu ils savent très bien qu'ils
doivent fermer leurs maisons sortir
s'ils ont des bonbonnes de gaz les
rentrées surtout former des volets parce
qu'une maison c'est très rare qu'est
keller brûle si tout est fermé
en pratique les habitants géré le risque
différemment lucien bur qui est né à
cisco il ya quelques jours il s'est
enfui de sa maison avec son épouse les
flammes étaient dans le jardin quand on
s'est rendu compte que ce devenir
dangereux moi je préférais partir être
en décembre même type ba et surveiller
le feu le besoin de 60 peut rien faire
nous a sauvés c'est le vent c'est tout
vivre dans l'angoissé prendre des
décisions vitales
le feu est une épreuve régulière qu'il
accepte ou à la corse c'est cisco
et je dirais même plus fort c'est d'être
à pied à mon petit hameau on paie ou de
signer
aujourd'hui dans toute la corse le
risque incendie est toujours jugée
sévère pour moi j'ai découvert la dame
le métier de sapeurs forestiers je
savais pas que ça existait bonsoir
paul-arnaud bonsoir merci beaucoup est
avec nous vous êtes géographe
biogéographe professeur à l'école
normale supérieure de fontenay saint
cloud est votre dernier niveau plaisir
des forêts promenade sous les feuillages
du monde est paru chez fayard la planète
a toujours volé oui depuis très très
longtemps
depuis des millions d'années oui et
normandes écosystèmes qui sont adaptés
fonctionner avec le feu qu'est ce qui se
passe en ce moment est ce que là aussi
vous nous dites oui on est arrivé à un
stade où on est confronté un
bouleversement climatique qui se traduit
par des incendies finalement comme on en
a rarement connu
non je ne dis pas ça alors je dis que
depuis des dizaines d'années bon an mal
an il ya 15 millions d'hectares c'est à
dire au moins la superficie de la forêt
française par le monde qui part en fumée
et avec des assauts redit dont on ne
parle pas les incendies a connu ceux qui
tapent dans la forêt boréale au canada
où il ya personne ce qui affecte la
forêt sibérienne dans l'homme oublié ni
si on n'en parle pas mais j'étais
scotché devant moi j'étais stupéfait de
voir que ça brûlait au groenland
or visiblement pour vous c'est pas une
surprise oui ça brûle aussi en france le
marais de la grande brière la tourbe si
à certains moments c'est très sec et qui
a de la foudre ou à quelque chose qui
provoque de la sordi et là vous avez un
feu courant à feu couvant qui peut durer
des semaines des mois et surtout faire
de la fumée plus que de la flamme c'est
pas un incendie on est obligé de se
sauver de bord et qui met ça existe et
ça existe dans les zones tempérées
ça existe dans la forêt amazonienne il
ya des feux de tourbes iliad et où il ya
des endroits des marécages et il peut y
avoir ce même type de cheveux que vous
pouvez quand même en quelques mots nous
expliquer la notion de feux de tourbe
parce que je pense que ça on surprend un
certain nombre ce soir à la tourbe c'est
de parler moi un feu qui se déclenche
naturellement mais il ya un moment où il
faut une il faut une flamme où il faut
une étoile un feu de tourbe dans la
grande brière par exemple ça pouvait
aussi d'aider
dans c'est souvent quand il ya des
sociétés rurales où des touristes on
peut laisser traîner un mégot mal éteint
dhr mais en prenant de l'âge eux ça peut
aussi être une cause naturelle à la
foudre peut mettre le feu et surtout
c'est des régions où on était il ya des
anticyclones énorme et il fait des 30 35
40 degrés dans le coeur du canada dans
le coeur de la sibérie et aux grandes
langues donc rien à voir avec le
réchauffement climatique
si le réchauffement climatique ça doit
c'est pas neutre la glace fond le
groenland redevient de plusieurs grün
landaas comme le pays vert et il devient
de plus en plus vers donc il ya de plus
en plus des espaces découverts qui ne
sont plus recouvert par la glace et où
il ya des possibilités de la sordide
mais tout peut brider la tour me dans le
sol
les herbes et les arbres je m'arrête un
instant sur la situation du canada pour
nous tous de notre imaginaire et
pardonnez moi mais physiquement c'est le
pays de la forêt on est d'accord oui
bien si ce pays est touché comme ça en
ce moment on se dit voilà encore un
poumon de notre planète qui est en train
d'être atteints alors est ce que c'est
une petite tumeur ponctuelles et on peut
la réduire ou est ce que c'est quelque
chose de plus grave quand on voit un
pays comme le canada j'allais vous dire
qu'ils s'enflamment qu'est ce que ça
vous inspire comme comme réaction comme
commentaire vous spécialistes qui sauf
la miss est toujours enflammée et on en
parle plus parce que c'est dans des
zones urbanisées c'est en
colombie-britannique
l'an dernier c'était près des endroits
où on faisait des extractions de
schistes bitumineux et donc on en a
énormément parlé
sinon il ya il ya des millions
d'hectares qui brûlent sans que personne
ne s'en préoccupe le ont réussi parce
qu'on s'en préoccupe pas que c'est pas
important ont intéressé mais ça l'est ça
existe c'est ça mais on survalorise les
incendies les incendies méditerranéen
c'est une petite chose à l'échelle de la
planète par rapport aux incendies de la
forêt boréale ou de la forêt
intertropicale mais c'est ce dont on
parle le plus alors je me sens et les
grandes rivières à touristique c'est les
endroits où il ya oui et dorée moment et
où il ya de l'interface fort et habitat
oui parce qu'on passe qu'on la voit pas
ce que des gens y habiter que on se sent
je vais dire pour des raisons de
proximité immédiatement concernés mais
parlez moi il y à des incendies par
exemple dans la forêt amazonienne
oui à des plus grands incendies des 50
dernières
c'est dans la forêt d'haguenau d'ado
neziha bornéo et eu entre 6 millions et
8 millions d'hectares dans un seul à
sordi et en forêt tropicale dense donc y
en a partout des as ordi ça tape partout
meillonnas cre dont on parle plus que
d'ogeu fait suite au reportage
d'alexandre paix louis civile quand ça
brûle comme on vient de le voir en corse
on replante où on laisse la nature faire
son boulot le mieux c'est de laisser
faire la nature parce que replanter
souvent vous replanter avec une seule
essence vous faites du bono spécifiques
c'est une fausse bonne solution donc le
mieux c'est de laisser repartir les
arbousiers les petits chênes kermès les
chênes liège qui sont peut-être passés
au travers de la sortie parce qu'ils ont
une écorce qui les protège et comme un
prêteur peut être là aussi quand ils
veulent et grande tempête de 99
le mieux c'est d'essayer de la
reconstitution naturelle et puis après
on observe on voit si ça marche pas ou
si certaines essences mais la nature
elle ça fait des millions d'années
qu'elle s'est cicatrisée pas mal de
choses et ça a forcément un impact non
ça repousse naturellement comme si de
rien n'était ben oui le parc de
yellowstone qui a brûlé il ya une
vingtaine d'années c'était que de la
cendre et c'est reparti et vous revenez
deux ans après à un grand incendie
c'est ouvert ça explose la la la la
reconquête c'est quelque chose
d'impressionnant et la nature etc
cicatriser une dernière question jean
marc jancovici avons nous séparer en
vous remerciant l'un et l'autre des deux
venus nous éclairer sur cette situation
qu'est ce que vous avez envie qu'on
conserve à l'esprit ce soir lorsqu'on
parle de réchauffement climatique
vous êtes un pédagogue compliqué fuite
ça vous a poussé à faire un choix et
être bref je savais faire aussi
compliqué
peut-être alors tout le monde va
défendre sa chapelle mais ça fait partie
de ça fait partie de ces sujets qu'on ne
saura jamais réglé autrement qu'à nos
dépens dit autrement la situation
n'évoluera jamais autrement cadeaux
dépend si on n'en fait pas un problème
dont on s'occupe partout et tout le
temps
un petit peu c'est à dire que si on s'y
lot en disant tiens il ya la séquence
changement climatique puis demain il y
aura la séquence retraite et après
demain la séquence n'est pas quoi on est
sûr de ne jamais rien faire de sérieux
en la matière merci beaucoup
l'un et l'autre d'avoir participé à
cette émission merci jean marc jancovici
merci paul arnaud alice le reste de
l'actualité